I mean the character starts at a 10. uh
but we like seeing Glenn Howerton out of
10. Mike hi there are three reasons why
people buy our phones do you know what
they are for email they work
yeah
yeah it's not US Gym is the carrier
Verizon is doing something weird okay
well I'm about to do something weird if
you don't fix this now every frame that
you are in is so compelling my only
complaint is that you are not in every
single segment of the film I could have
watched that guy brush his teeth I could
I could have watched the story of that
guy from the beginning to end and I like
the other story too and I like the movie
a lot of movies great but holy man
you're so good oh man thank you
I have a prediction the prediction is
this within a month of this movie coming
out the phone is going to be ringing for
Glenn May 12th everybody go out and see
double feature